wir haben uns bisher in einer
trügerischen sicherheit gebogen es war
ein irrtum zu glauben auf der erde
würden nur sehr selten asteoriden
einschlagen das gegenteil ist der fall
und wir müssen handeln jetzt in klicks
um science-fiction
diese meldung ist eine deutliche warnung
an die menschheit die erde steht unter
einem ständigen bombardement durch
gefährliche asteroiden damit hat sich
die einschätzung der wahrscheinlichkeit
eines einschlages dramatisch geändert
bisher wurde davon ausgegangen dass zum
beispiel der asteroid von tscheljabinsk
eine seltene ausnahme und außerdem nicht
so gefährlich gewesen sei das ist aber
ein trugschluss der zoe der letztes jahr
aufgrund seines einschlag winkels fast
komplett verglüht ist hätte in einem
anderen winkel eine großstadt komplett
zerstört verglichen mit der hiroshima
bombe hatte er die 40 fache sprengkraft
entsprechend tnt werden es 600
kilotonnen die atombombe über hiroshima
abgeworfen wurde hatte eine sprengkraft
entsprechend 15 kilotonnen tnt es ist
noch ein größeres exemplar letztes jahr
sehr dicht an der erde vorbeigeflogen
2012 dh 14 flog unterhalb der
geostationären satelliten ganz knapp an
der erde vorbei allerdings änderte der
erst dabei seine flugbahn
ist also groß von einem solch riesigen
himmelskörper getroffen zu werden und
auch nur sehr schwer einzuschätzen da
die asteroiden auch ihre flugbahn öfter
ändern das geschieht auch ganz ohne den
vorbeiflug an großen planeten zb durch
die einschläge von anderen kleinen hast
du ihnen immer mehr wissenschaftler
warnen jetzt vor dem hohen risiko eines
großen einschlags auf der erde wie oft
hat es in den letzten 13 jahren passiert
ist wurde erst jetzt bekannt
26 asteroiden sind auf der erde
eingeschlagen darauf gekommen sind
findige wissenschaftler sie hatten die
idee beim weltweiten atomteststopp
überwachungs netzwerk nachzufragen ob es
andere größere explosionen auf der erde
gab und es waren
26 und es konnten nur hast du ihnen
einschläge sei nichts anderes hat eine
solche wucht und lediglich ein einschlag
wurde dabei vorher gesehen alle anderen
kamen im wahrsten sinne des wortes aus
heiterem himmel jedes jahr schlagen also
zwei größere asteroiden hier auf der
erde ein bisher hatten wir großes glück
denn die gesteinsbrocken studien mehr in
wüsten oder sonstigen unbewohnten
gebieten ein und verdampften bereits in
der atmosphäre
wie hoch ist also das risiko wirklich
wie schnell ein asteroid oder komet auf
einem planeten einschlagen kann wurde
1994 deutlich der komet shoemaker levy
ist ein beeindruckendes beispiel
entdeckt wurde er am 24 märz in unser 93
und am 16 juli 1994 also nur gut ein
jahr später schlugen die ersten
bruchstücke auf dem jupiter ein sie
hatten eine sprengkraft von 50 millionen
hiroshima bomben der jupiter hat
allerdings ein deutlich größeres und
stärkeres gravitationsfeld als die erde
also erzielt mehr an aber trotzdem ist
das risiko auch hier auf der erde hoch
millionen und abermillionen
gesteinsbrocken rasen durch unser
sonnensystem und dabei sind die zahlen
allein für unseren planeten ziemlich
beeindruckend es wird vermutet dass etwa
eine million asteroiden sich im bereich
der erdumlaufbahn befinden davon kennen
wir 10.000 das ist exakt 1 prozent eine
expertengruppe des united nations office
for auto space erfährt also das büro der
vereinten nationen für weltraum
angelegenheiten will dieses jahr
vorschläge unterbreiten was bei einem
drohenden einschlag eines asteroiden mit
einer größe von mehr als einem kilometer
getan werden kann bei einem solchen
anschlag ist mit der vernichtung der
erde bzw den meisten leben auf der erde
zu rechnen zunächst konzentriert sich
die expertengruppe auf diesen armageddon
fallen eine idee liegt dort schon vor
kleinere asteroiden sollen zum einschlag
auf großen asteroiden gebracht werden um
ihre flugbahn zu ändern eine andere
gruppe will sich um die kleineren
exemplare kümmern die noch nicht einmal
gefunden wurden ehemalige astronauten um
den space shuttle piloten etwa wollen
asteroiden finden die zumindest städte
länder und kontinente zerstören können
damit sie frühzeitig erkannt werden will
ihre organisation wie fix 112 einen
privat finanzierten satelliten in den
weltraum schicken der die ersten mit
einer kamera aufspürt wir müssen handeln
und vielleicht hat die erforschung des
weltraums hier auch seine bestimmung
gefunden das überleben der menschheit zu
sichern mehr infos zu diesem thema und
täglich mehr science news in der
kostenlosen pixum ab hier klicken und
das gibt's natürlich für android und ios
allerdings auch in der video
beschreibung und hier
geht es zum letzten video pixum science
and history über die grösste
atomkatastrophe
der menschheit die kernschmelze in
tschernobyl nicht würde jetzt
interessieren sollen wir wirklich so
viel geld für das auffinden von
asteroiden ausgeben oder wird das risiko
hier überschätzen diskutiertes in den
kommentaren also bis dann
bleibt dran
[Musik]